haven't been used at this point and I've done just fine by it. I did have an appointment yesterday
with my aunt for no thanks. What's what you take on this? Do you really have to ask me that question?
I guess so. Okay, so you do not know me very well, do you? So I'm just teasing you. Sorry,
but no, if should you get the flu shot? So I'm trying to think of a reason why someone would want to
get a flu shot. And I'm at loss for words. So there's multiple reasons why you wouldn't want to
get a flu shot. Yeah. And one being that it's not going to really protect you from the flu,
there are so many varieties of influenza out there by the end of March when
quote unquote flu season is starting to die down. The Centers of Disease Control will have
identified on the average between 700 and 1200 varieties of the flu that have been out that they
identified over the course of the last six months. Now they use those to decide on what to put
in next year's vaccine, which they only could pick maximum of three. So they'll pick three things
to put in next year's vaccine. You do the math on that and it's just idiotic to think that
getting a flu shot is going to help you prevent you from getting the flu. Secondly, in order for a
vaccine to work, it has to stimulate a TH1 and a TH2 or a B cell reaction and develop antibodies
against that virus or bacteria that you're trying to to vaccinate that person against. So just
because a person gets a vaccine does not mean that they have immunity against that particular
organism that they're vaccinated themselves from, which is absolutely evident in amount of people
that got the flu that had the flu shot. And it's evident in all these outbreaks of measles
of people that got the measles vaccination. And all the other outbreaks of diseases, all these
most of these people were vaccinated. And yet they blame unvaccinated people for spreading this.
It's like, okay, if you're vaccinated, then what in the world are you worried about this infection
that's going around that you're supposed to have antibodies against? Well, the truth is they don't
measure antibodies in that person. Years and years ago, they would give a person a vaccination.
And then three weeks later, they would measure that person's blood for antibodies against that
thing that they've vaccinated against. And if they didn't have antibodies, they would re-vaccinate
that person or re-inoculate that person because it didn't work. Well, they stop doing that because
why? Because they don't like doctor's visits and making more money. No, because the high
percentage of people that the vaccine didn't even work against. So I could go on and on for about
two hours on the subject of vaccination. But vaccination is not the way to develop an immune system
and not the way to develop an effective response against any organism in your environment. So
there, I think I've made multiple videos on vaccine. There's tons of information on vaccines.
I would highly suggest if you feel pressured by family members or doctors about the subject that you
Google. There's a movie called Vax. Vax, that's a documentary that's wonderful. There's other
documentaries that can really enlighten you on this subject and will probably inflame your anger
at what the whole vaccine industry is doing to the populist as a whole because it's damaging people.
It's leaving people with brain inflammation. It's leaving kids with ADD, ADHD and all sorts of problems.
And it's a crime against humanity in the very least.
Many people believe that it's an attempt to limit population control. And that has been proven
out with vaccines that have been administered in Africa where young girls are sterile because of that.
No. And I could go on and on and it's not conspiracy theory stuff anymore. I used to lecture against
vaccines 20 years ago when I was a total crackpot considered by everybody. Well, I'm still considered
that, but it's now a badge of honor. So thank you very much. But I would highly recommend that you
that you go to YouTube. There's a lot of people that are a lot smarter than I am that were very much
in the pro vaccine camp. I heard a wonderful woman, Dr. Kelly, if she's on here probably remembers
the lady's name. I'm talking about a spoke at Ben Lynch's seminar a couple years ago who worked for
the CDC. And she was she did a lot of work in the pro vaccine movement and tell her eyes or a light
that she now speaks against it. And she literally fears for her life. So took way too much time to say,
no, don't get vaccinated. Don't get vaccinated. Hey, I appreciate that.
Well, I'm not getting press anybody, but thank you for the input. Yeah. I think some of the schools
like they won't let the kids in unless I heard of that mom they got thrown in jail for not. Yeah,
there are some states that that do not have a the ability for you to just to opt out. I know
in Minnesota, in many states have three different ways to opt out. You can opt out via a religious
exemption. There's an exemption just for a parent to say we don't want to do this or you could get
a doctor to sign the exemption for them saying this is not in the best interest of the patient.
So there's a few states that are very controlled by the pharmaceutical industry.
Connecticut's one of them. I don't know all the state laws, but there's some states that are
forcing children to be vaccinated in order to go to school. I know California is is very pro vaccine.
And so as an adult, you have the option to opt out unless you're in a career like a doctor at a
hospital or a nurse at a hospital where you're forced to get a vaccine in order to continue to work
there. But there's a lot back against that. I was so impressed that the hospital that I go to.
One of the nurses was wearing a mask and I said she goes I'm not sick. She said but I won't get
the flu vaccine so they make me wear this. Yeah, and I give her credit for wearing that. Yeah,
that's right. Because she of her conviction. That's right. And that would you also say that like when
they tell you you can't get sick from the vaccine. I know people who get sick right after the shot
is that true? I would just say you're a misinformed in person. So I wouldn't say that at all quite
honestly because I wouldn't be in the position to have to say that because I wouldn't have gone to
them in the first place. But if I was in that position, I would be nice and I'd say thank you very much.
And I would bite my tongue. But what I would like to say is in a whole different story. But it's
you know, you give up arguing with people that don't want to have their eyes open. And you're just
basically casting your pearls before swine and we're told not to do that. So yeah, just say no thank you
ahead and move on. And if they argue with you, put your fingers in your ear and go la la la la la la
works for me every time.